[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we're going to be discussing Dementors
if you don't order Dementors already
then you've probably been watching the
wrong franchise however if we don't
properly define what a Dementor is it
will be hard to argue whether or not
they can die so I'm going to start with
a brief introduction
Dementors are cloaked creatures that are
three meters tall with dark gray scabby
skin demanders are foul creatures that
represent unhappiness and despair they
are commonly known as the guards of
Azkaban prison responsible for ensuring
that all of the darkest witches and
wizards inside don't escape Dementors
were originally created by JK Rowling as
a way of representing depression
JK Rowling having experienced depression
herself wanted to create a creature that
personified all of the negative aspects
of depression when in an interview
Rowling was asked to describe what
depression feels like she said the
following it is that absence of being
able to envisage that you will ever be
cheerful again the absence of hope that
very deadening feeling which is so very
different from feeling sad sad hurts but
it's a healthy feeling it's a necessary
thing to feel depression is very
different which sounds entirely
consistent with this independent
description of Dementors Dementors are
among the Fallas creatures that walk
this earth they invest the darkest
filthiest places they glory and decay in
despair they drain peace hope and
Happiness out of the air around them
even muggles feel their presence though
they can't see them get too near a
Dementor and every good feeling every
happy memory will be sucked out of you
if it can the Dementor will feed on you
long enough to reduce you to something
like itself soulless and evil you'll be
left with nothing but the worst
experiences of your life in the Prisoner
of Azkaban
Harry witnesses Demento firsthand
Harry's sense of helplessness during
this experience was perfectly described
in the following excerpt an intense call
trucked over the mall Harry felt his own
breath catch in his chest the cold went
deeper than his skin it was inside his
chest it was inside his very heart
Harry's eyes rolled up into his head he
couldn't see he was drowning in cold
there was a rushing in his ears as
though of water he was being dragged
downward the roaring growing louder and
then from far away he
screaming terrible terrified pleading
screams he wanted to help whoever it was
he tried to move his arms but couldn't a
thick white fog was swirling around him
inside him
so our Dementors Living can they die
there are two theories for how Dementors
are created the first outlines that
Dementors do not breed so to speak but
actually grow like fungus under
conditions of despair degradation and
hopelessness the greater the
concentration of these conditions the
more Dementors will appear the second
theory is the Dementors do in fact breed
and while we don't have more information
on this it's supported by the fact that
fudge in half-blood prince mentions that
they're breeding and that the breeding
was the cause of all the mists present
in the sky regardless of how they're
created one thing is for sure they are
not living creatures there's something
in between we know that the only known
defense against the Dementor is the
Patronus charm which Harry shows us time
and time again a Patronus is a good
defense against Dementors because it
produces a positive energy force that
represents everything that Dementors
aren't the Patronus represents hope
happiness survival and purity as the
Patronus does not feel despair or
hopelessness as a human might the
Dementors can't hurt it and are repelled
by its presence but even though they're
repelled by it
it doesn't appear to damage them or hurt
them it definitely doesn't kill them so
if there's only one way to repel a
Dementor and it doesn't kill them can
they be killed can something that's not
alive be killed are they alive JK
Rowling sort of addresses this in the
following quote you cannot destroy
Dementors that you can limit their
numbers if you eradicate the conditions
in which they multiply
I eat spare and degradation but this
quote doesn't necessarily indicate that
they are immortal it just means that we
can't destroy them what she's saying is
that there is no spell potion or curse
that will eradicate them the Ministry of
Magic Classifieds Dementors as non
beings also known as non-human spiritus
apparitions this classification refers
to creatures formed out of human
emotions sounds like a perfect
description for demented
what we need to remember about non
beings is that they aren't mortal or
immortal they are immortal this means
that they aren't able to die because
they were never really alive they are a
raw magical presence that only gives the
appearance of being alive when you cast
a Patronus on a Dementor it
Awards it off or revert it back to his
inchoate essence or rudimentary form we
see a similar sort of remission in
physical form to a lesser extent in
Voldemort after he's destroyed by his
rebounding killing curse but even though
the Demento had stopped for a period of
time it's never really destroyed for
good the Dementor is just reduced to a
lesser form a form where it's not able
to inflict the same harm that it
normally could if you were to place this
lesser form back into an environment of
despair degradation and hopelessness
then it would likely assume it's full
form again however with the presence of
a Patronus
and all the positive emotions that it
brings with it it is not a suitable
environment for the Dementor to recreate
itself we can draw more parallels to
depression here as when you are able to
overcome depression it isn't that those
underlying feelings or thoughts have
completely escaped you it's just that
you've overcome them when you've
overcome depression you've created a new
environment in your mind that is no
longer conducive to perpetuating these
negative thoughts if you're a happier
person in general then it gives these
negative thoughts less ground to stand
on which means that they would have less
influence on your being overall I hope
that answers the question and I hope
that you guys enjoyed the video if you
enjoy the content please remember to
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]